good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight here's an interesting
observation slash theory
the slogans that yell the loudest are
the ones they believe the least we've
been noticing that recently volume is
inversely proportional to sincerity
maybe you scream it because you don't
really believe it
why do we think this well here's why the
very same people who've told us for
decades now that it's my body my choice
and seemed to mean it when they said it
those same people abandoned their own
argument immediately when kovit arrived
suddenly on a dime they turned and they
were demanding that we wear the mask and
get the shot
but these were not optional suggestions
they weren't deeply personal decisions
to be made according to the dictates of
individual conscience after consulting
with family physicians and clergy they
weren't between you your doctor and god
no not at all these were mandates
all of a sudden democrats were arguing
that actually politicians do get to
decide what you do with your body it's
their choice not yours inject these
powerful drugs whether you want to or
not because we own you
now whatever else that is that is not a
pro-choice position to put it mildly
so as we watched this happen we wondered
what are these people going to say the
next time so-called abortion rights get
challenged in court and now we know the
answer because last night the supreme
court of the united states ruled on a
new abortion law in the state of texas
that decision came down by the way 5-4
that's the exact split that decided roe
v wade almost 50 years ago so it's good
enough to have meaning
this time the court upheld a texas law
that effectively bans abortion once a
fetal heartbeat is detected typically
that's about six weeks into a pregnancy
now this new law does not allow the
government of texas to enforce the ban
so no one's going to jail over abortion
instead the new law let citizens sue
clinics that commit illegal abortions
so no matter how you feel about abortion
it's kind of hard to argue this is an
especially radical law
intentionally stopping a person's heart
from beating is the definition of
killing government has a right to
regulate that in fact deciding when it's
okay to kill a person is on the most
basic level the whole reason to have
laws in the first place
so whether it's right or wrong or
whether you like it or not it's not a
crazy statute
it did however drive the media crazy
here's cbs quote news last night
it is nearly impossible to get an
abortion in texas the most restrictive
abortion law in the country went into
effect after the u.s supreme court
declined to act on a request to block it
abortion providers say texas has
essentially outlawed 85 percent of
abortion procedures which will force
many clinics to close
amy hagster miller runs four clinics
providing abortion services and is one
of the plaintiffs asking the supreme
court to intervene it's heartbreaking to
deny them the care that our staff are
fully trained
and ready to provide so really most
people are going to be forced to carry a
pregnancy against their will
the law signed by republican governor
greg abbott bans abortion once a
so-called fetal heartbeat is detected
usually around six weeks
how is an abortion service different
from abortion why not just call it what
it is but here's the best line from cbs
a so-called fetal heartbeat
imagine saying something like that out
loud once they've decided you should die
they won't even admit you have a
heartbeat do the very worst people in
this country go into journalism or does
it just seem that way anyway you'll
notice that cbs does not make a case for
abortion no they didn't tell you why
it's so important to stop fetal hearts
from beating they just asserted that it
is
what they didn't do is say a single word
of how this violates your physical
autonomy but how it's your body your
choice
they can't say that now they're for
mandating vaccines and masks
so in that way over at cbs they're still
a little bit smarter than the protesters
you're seeing on your screen right now
these are the people who gathered
outside the texas state capitol in
austin today you'll notice that many of
them are holding signs affirming their
physical autonomy you can't tell them
what to do with their bodies politicians
hands off my body
but wait a second at the very same
moment they're declaring their physical
autonomy they're wearing their little
obedience masks and you can bet money
all of them are vaccinated why because
they were told to get the shot so of
course they obeyed
they don't see the irony here
on the other hand how could they see it
so few sane people are left with big
platforms in this country that you
almost never hear a sensible logical
rational argument about anything
just hours ago for example the aclu the
american civil liberties union released
this statement and we're quoting
far from compromising them vaccine
mandates actually further civil
liberties
you have more civil liberties when they
control your body
you can just imagine the 1860s version
far from compromising civil liberties
slavery actually enhances personal
freedom
it's not even orwellian at this point
it's post or well this is uncharted
things are changing so fast that a lot
of people on the left are having trouble
keeping up with the shifting
justifications for the policies they
want poor gensake
never a genius to begin with
unintentionally blew herself up today at
the white house press briefing watch
this
why does the president support abortion
when his own catholic faith teaches
abortion is morally wrong
he believes that it's a woman's right
it's a woman's body and it's her choice
who does he believe then should look out
for the unborn child he believes that
it's up to a woman to make those
decisions and up to a woman to make
those decisions with her doctor i know
you've never faced those choices nor
have you ever been pregnant but for
women out there who have faced those
choices this is an incredibly difficult
thing
oh getting the sophomore year gender
studies lecture from jen saki here at
wesley and mr man men and girls don't
get to talk about abortion you ever been
pregnant before i don't think so you
can't get pregnant because you're a man
so abortion is a women's issue shut up
they've been saying that for so long
they forgot to update the talking points
you'd think gensake when she does this
for a living she should know
that men get pregnant now the science
people tell us that every day men get
pregnant it's on the cover of magazines
think it's on the cover of people
magazine right now a dude who's pregnant
now what does that mean
it means that abortion is now a men's
issue men are child bearers so men
dudes have an equal right to choose to
terminate their pregnancies
and they have a right to weigh in on the
policy itself
it's not a women's issue anymore gensake
she may get an outrage call from
congresswoman corey bush of st louis who
was on this early watch
i sit before you today
as a single mom as a nurse as an
activist and as a congresswoman and i am
committed to doing the absolute most to
protect black mothers to protect black
babies to
protect black birthing people
see cory bush is on this maybe she
should be white house press secretary
she knows it's not a woman's choice
it's a birthing people choice
so how is it an attack on women
to ban abortion in texas
a tough one
they're not really sure
so in msnbc they're not even trying to
explain they just want you to know that
if you're for this law in texas you're
the taliban
and we have a situation in texas right
now tonight
where the american taliban because
that's what it is there's not an
american evangelical right-wing movement
there is an american taliban
is weirdly similar in so many ways to
the middle eastern islamist terrorists
you just feel so sorry for these people
america is again changing so fast that
like people over 16 who weren't on tick
tock half that they just can't keep up
there was a time like two weeks ago when
the taliban were bad
before they were a critical member of
the international community who were
talking daily with the secretary of
state the national security adviser and
waiting for their american
aid
the american taliban no that's different
unfortunately unlike the poshtune
taliban no one in texas is getting tens
of billions in free weapons from joe
biden the national rights life is
getting blackhawks or 360 000 ar-15s
so it's a little different actually to
be the american taliban but
the taliban's still bad no they're good
we need to update our talking points
but still
this msnbc anchor the most fiery in
their lineup wants you to know that if
you tell people
what to do with their bodies you're a
bad person unless
you're tony fauci in which case you're
america's doctor and a hero the whole
thing she said reminds her of that book
she once read maybe the only book she's
read listen
by next summer
we could be living in our own version of
the handmaid's tale where forced birth
is the law
in large sections of the country you
know and senator warren
you know
people
think it's hyperbolic uh when i tweet
about the handmaid's tale coming to
america
but i don't think it seems hyperbolic
now does it to you
no
it's like
it's like
the greatest question ever asked
elizabeth warren does this seem
hyperbolic to you
is there anything you can say to
elizabeth warren where she might reply
that seems hyperbolic to me not you're
going too far there slow down a little
bit reign in your rhetoric
[Laughter]
but when msnbc trots out elizabeth
warren doesn't matter what she says the
point is she's there this is a serious
moment
cnn had to top it and they did they went
farther even than msnbc to assess
yesterday's court decision on abortion
cnn found a man with personal experience
that would be jeffrey toobin now tubin
is most famous for masturbating on zoom
that will define his obit unfortunately
there may not be room for a much more
relevant fact which is jeffrey toobin
once impregnated a co-worker's daughter
and then pressured her to get an
abortion
gene knows this topic cold now she
refused but in the process of pushing
her to get an abortion unsuccessfully
jeffrey tubin learned what a lot of
crappy men have learned over the years
which is
this is a great option if you're a
married guy who doesn't want to pay for
more kids with random women so jeffrey
tubin means it when he tells you it's
bad to ban it watch
today is the first day that a state
could legally ban abortion and roe v
wade essentially does not exist at least
in the state of texas and probably more
it states to come texas has banned
abortion in the state and the supreme
court has done nothing about it that is
immensely significant mostly for the
women of texas 29 million people in
total live in texas what does that mean
for roe v wade i said it could
effectively end roe v wade was that an
overstatement
i don't think so the point of roe v wade
is that states cannot ban abortion
it's immensely significant for the women
he mansplains they've been telling you
that for a long time when the truth is
every person who lives here knows
abortion is the best deal for the men
who impregnate say the daughters of
their coworkers because it allows them
to skate without having to deal with the
consequences abortion makes actual women
the ones who until recently were having
all the babies before dudes could get
pregnant it makes them feel pretty bad
about it if you ask women how do you
feel about the abortion not many feel
that great about it at all people like
jeffrey tube and feel fine so it's his
prerogative he's defending but whatever
there he is lecturing us about roe v
wade the sacred 5-4 ruling that invented
the right to abortion out of nothing
now here you have a duly elected state
legislature
right now in 2021
contradicting the five unelected judges
who conduct concocted the right to
abortion back in 1973 and jeffrey toobin
is suggesting that's an attack on
democracy
when elected people
contravene the judgment of unelected
people who died decades ago that's what
they're telling you these people can't
even hear themselves
but millions of normal americans do
recognize this moment for what it is
it's proof that democracy does still
exist voters can decide what they want
for their communities their states their
towns
and that courts would at least
potentially respect that right it's
called self-government
the legislature in texas has realized
this for months now they've passed laws
banning vaccine passports homeless
encampments racist struggle sessions in
schools laws that
block protests that prevent emergency
vehicles from riding down the road etc
etc laws specific to texas that the
people of texas want and a lot of those
laws are still on the books so that's
not a bad thing how is that a bad thing
why should texas have to be exactly like
california
the problem is
if that kind of thinking
goes national
it gravely disempowers the people at cnn
and the so-called civil rights
organizations that think they're in
control of everything in the other hand
it might actually save civil rights for
the rest of us and that might be a good
thing hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else